Yes, ma'am. First of all, we have the ERP login which will be campus.audipay.org.
This is campus.audipay.org.
This is a URL which we share with you so that you can attach it to your homescreen.
Your login will be via phone number and OTP.
If you have a phone number, you can log in via OTP.
If you log in via OTP, you can log in via OTP.
If you have the option to set your password, you can set it on your password.
After opening, our dashboard appears like this.
This will be your company PRT interface.
Your entity's name will be shown here.
This is my ID.
Your name will be created in my ID.
The name of your institute will be created.
After that, we have the top session here.
The session in which you have opened.
The further your distance sessions will be created, the problem will be created.
You can search for sessions.
Now, let's talk about the interface.
For example, we will have separate admission and admission fees.
If you see, all these options are appearing.
This is our permission-based structure.
The student will have the admission interface.
The fee will only have the fee options.
We have a quick link option.
For example, for me, some options are used on a daily basis.
For example, for the fee at week or for the fee clerk, the collect fee option will be used on a daily basis.
You can add a quick link for yourself.
For example, if you add a quick link, the collect fee will come here.
I can directly access the student's fee on daily basis.
This means that this N number of links can be updated according to each user.
This is how your interface will be.
Now, let me show you how we have set up the fee.
The collect fee is at the top.
From here, you can only collect.
From the collect fee option, you have the collect fee online option.
You can also add the online fee separately.
Otherwise, you can also collect from the collect fee online option.
You can also collect from the first option.
This is how you have two or three different options.
You can also collect from the collect fee online option.
You can also add it to your session.
We have added a student after testing.
You can search for the student by its name.
You can also search for the student's registration number.
You can also search for the student's father's name, phone number.
You can search for the student from various options.
You will search for the student and the student will appear.
Some details will be shown on the interface.
You can verify the student.
You will click on this.
From here, the student's fee collection section will be opened.
Here, the student's personal details are there.
Then, what is the fee demand?
I have added the student to Paytech Civil.
We have added the total fee of the student in the first year.
We have added a fresh application.
They have taken a fresh application for a literal entry.
There is a goal.
If the student is in the second year or third year, then you are the only student.
We have added a fresh application and a literal entry.
Here, the total fee is coming.
If you ask the student for concession, then concession comes.
After concession, the fee will come to you.
The fee will be received by the student.
Then the balance of the fee will come.
From here, they can redirect the student to concession.
You can click on this and make a concession.
We have not made a concession group yet.
Share your concession groups.
50% of the criteria is concession.
You can also make a movie like this.
Send me a criteria.
Send me the fee structure.
We will add a criteria for concession.
According to the student, if there is a concession, then it will be imported.
If you want to add a new one, I will tell you.
Anju, add a man-to-concession.
Ok.
First of all, we have put a due demand.
Here you have an installment.
There are four installments.
By default, your first installment will come.
The date you have given will be automatically selected according to the date.
If the due date is the second installment, then it will be automatically selected in the second installment.
If you select all, then all the installments will be selected.
The student's total pay is all.
This is the overall fee.
According to the case installment fee.
We have made this now.
If you think there will be any changes, then this will be the case.
Because ma'am, it is possible that our amount will change now.
Yes, that is possible.
I meant the interface.
You made it that we will take this much in August, then in November, then in February.
Ok.
This is ok.
You take it like this in August, November, May.
There is one more option in this.
It is possible that the student's fee is this.
I will select all the installments.
For example, you have to take one installment.
But the student does not pay so much now.
You have to enter the amount according to yourself.
There is one option.
You can enter the amount directly here.
For example, the student is paying 10,000 now.
You will enter according to yourself.
10,000.
The first fee head will get the first fee head.
He will take all the fees from that.
In case you feel that you have to pay according to yourself, you can do that too.
You have a cycle here.
You can do according to yourself.
You have to take 2,000 in this.
You have to take 1,000 in this.
You are paying according to yourself.
Ma'am, excuse me ma'am.
By default, you are saying that the fees in the tuition fee, what will the tuition fee get first?
Will the tuition fee get first or something else?
This is the head sequence.
You have the first tuition fee here.
You can get the head sequence according to yourself.
Because we also have tuition fee in this.
So, first the tuition fee, then the security, then the tuition fee.
This should be done like this.
First, tell me the head sequence.
I will note it down.
First comes the security, then the tuition fee.
Then the transport and also.
First, there will be security, then the tuition fee.
Then transport and hostel.
Transport and hostel.
If someone has both transport and hostel, then there will be transport and hostel.
Ma'am, after that, I think...
All the fines and recharges should be done after this.
Before the fines, there should be all the fees like student fund, corpus fund, etc.
Fine should be done at the end.
Ma'am, we can also calculate the fines according to the date.
I will tell you that too.
Ma'am, after this, the student development fund will come.
Student fund, then development fund.
First is the development fund, then the student fund.
Whatever you have written.
This is the sequence and contribution.
There will be a sequence according to that.
When you do the collect, you have to show here.
In case if we are taking it by editing, then it will show here.
How much was the pay and how much you are taking from it.
This is also known to you.
I will show you a transition of one rupees.
Just to test.
You will be like this.
Then you have to proceed.
After proceeding, it will show you how much you are taking from it.
You have the payment mode.
You are getting cash, cheque, etc.
By default, cash is selected.
Now you have to check according to your payment.
Now it is a payment gate.
We have integrated the razor picker in it.
Should we do the razor picker in this too?
Ma'am, is it different in this?
No, it is the same.
I have not done the fee yet.
They need confirmation.
We have done the same in this too.
If there is a razor picker in both, then you will feel comfortable.
Yes, that is not an issue.
We need a confirmation.
What happens in that?
You select online from here.
You just have to select online fee.
It will directly integrate you.
It will tell you what to do.
I don't understand.
What did you say? Online fee?
You have two options.
One is collect online fee and the other is normal collect fee.
In this, collect fee means that you are collecting normal amount in cash and then collecting.
I will show you now.
In case you feel that you have been getting online from the beginning.
Or you have some back gate entries.
Or in some other way, you have cheque etc.
And you have to collect that by entering online.
So this is that case.
Your institute banks will be made here.
Whatever you tell, that institute banks will get it.
They will come to you to select.
You have to give a reference number corresponding to it.
You have to select a particular date.
These are all optional.
These are the options.
Then these are remarks.
If you are collecting fees, you have to enter some remarks.
Then the receipt will also be saved.
So these are the remarks options.
This will be the collect fee option.
You can use all these options for collect fee.
Now in case you will directly collect online from ERP.
Like you have given the scanner in front of you.
Or online you have given card or debit card.
If you are giving payment like this.
So in that case, what will happen?
You have to select online.
Collect online.
So here it will redirect you to payment gate.
Now payment gate is not signed.
That is why no payment gate is signed.
The scanner will come there.
It will be scanned and paid.
Now I will give you a transaction in cash.
I will give you a transaction in cash.
Some kids...
Meenakshi ma'am.
The kids who do it with the scanner.
Which category will they go to?
The ones who come later.
They do it with the scanner.
That we did it from home.
Yes, they do it through the app.
Will they come through collect online?
Or collect fee?
If the kids do it through the app.
They can't do it with Meenakshi ma'am.
Not app ma'am.
The kids who do it with the scanner.
They share it with their friends.
Now they have the one in the back.
They put it from home.
They only have screenshots.
Sometimes they bring it after 10 days.
Or after 5 days.
That it won't come through collect fee.
According to me.
Okay.
Now let's do one transaction.
One transaction for one rupee.
We will do it in cash.
As soon as you collect,
they will give you a confirmation.
You can still cancel it.
There will be confirmation that
you are receiving the amount of the date.
If you say okay,
they will receive your transaction.
And this is a format.
We have set it according to the office.
You can set it according to your office.
This is the format of the receipt.
Please share a logo with us.
Okay.
I think we have done it with you.
Yes.
We have also shared the logo
of the form you gave.
That only goes up.
It doesn't come to us.
It is better if you share it in the group.
Then I will integrate it in the app.
It goes to the document.
That is why.
Documents don't come to us.
This is the template of the receipt.
You can see it here.
You can change it according to it.
This is how it is installed.
This is how it is displayed.
This is customized.
You can customize it according to you.
Otherwise this will be recorded.
Okay.
This is the receipt of the receipt.
You can add the amount of the padding
according to it.
The remark you enter is displayed here.
Are the fines added now?
Yes.
Yes, 10th of August, 10th of November, like this.
Ok, so if you have August, September, October, then 10th of August will be the first installment.
Yes, the first installment.
Ok, so let's set the last date.
Yes, so for example, on 11th August, 500 will be set.
10th August will be set like this.
Everyone will have a fine config that you are saying in the system.
From 11th, how much did you tell? What is the percentage?
500.
500 for every day, right?
No, not every day. After 15 days, 500 is added.
Ok, so after 15 days, 500 is added. I will take it, then I will set it up.
Exactly. After the last fee date, 500 and after every 15 days, they will increase by 500.
Ok, so in the last day, 500 and after every 15 days, fine.
Yes.
Ok, so I will tell you how this fine will work. I have set it up.
After that, if you do collect fee, at the time of collect fee, you have a date here.
By default, the current date is coming.
For example, after 10th of August, 11th of August.
By default, if you come on 11th of August, you have to collect a little.
So in the end, you get a fine and the calculated fine shows up.
Ok.
Ma'am, if we have to do the fine like this, after the last date, it will cost 40 rupees.
And it keeps increasing by 40-40 every day. So that is also possible, right?
Ma'am, you will have to tell me which criteria you have to follow.
Ok.
Because earlier we had the 40-40 one.
Then when we were using software before this, we had the 500 one.
So we will tell you once by confirming which one we have.
You can confirm the fine easily.
By doing the fine confirmation, actually how the fine works.
If we set the fine, then you will understand that it will be applicable to every course and every student.
Yes.
It will work according to you.
Ok.
Ma'am, this is the interface.
Have you made a concession for Anjali?
Yes, ma'am.
Ok. For example, ma'am, there is a new student.
There is a fresh application.
You have to assign a concession.
Here you have an option.
You will click here and it will take you to the concession.
Ok.
Anjali, please share the screen.
Anjali, you have to tell me about the concession, right?
Yes.
Anjali, is the voice coming?
Yes, Anjali, it is coming.
What do I have to tell you, ma'am?
Tell me about the concession and how to assign it.
Ok.
Ma'am, what happens in this is that we have to select a concession here.
For example, we will make different heads of concessions according to the data that you will give us.
I have made a manual one.
You click the manual and assign it.
After assigning, we will set the amount here.
Either 10% or 1000.
It will be set according to the amount that you will give us.
Then we will set the remark.
According to the concession.
After that, we will save it.
One minute, Anjali.
Ma'am, what is the option in this?
For example, you have made it according to the percentage.
Right.
You think that you have fixed the student.
Yes, we have a sports concession.
There are different concession groups.
For example, there is a sports concession and you have to give it in the tuition fee.
That is 10%.
Right.
We have a master in the system.
We will define it there.
10% and only on the tuition fee.
The moment you select and assign, it will automatically calculate according to the fee.
10% will be made.
Ok.
Then at the bottom, there is also a manual.
You think that you have to keep a fixed amount or you have a manual in that case.
You think that you have to set the amount according to yourself.
In that case, the manual works.
Ok.
Select the concession group.
Then after that, come to the bottom once, Anjali.
Yes.
Here, ma'am, you have to enter the remark that why are you giving the concession.
Along with that, there is an option to choose the file.
Sometimes it happens with principles or an application signature.
You have to upload the application document.
Ok.
So that option remains.
This is not mandatory.
Basically, it is optional.
You can upload according to yourself.
If you feel that you have to upload a document in the concession.
Ok, ma'am.
Then save it with the remark.
It will be saved.
Remarks are mandatory.
Ok.
After that, after being assigned from here, you get the payable below.
You will know how much it is made.
Anjali, close this once.
Come down to the bottom.
You can collect directly from here.
You can also collect fee from here.
Ok.
Collect fee will be in the bottom and above.
You can also collect fee from the student above.
Ma'am, the payment history is coming.
The fee transactions have been cut.
The receipt is also shown in the payment history.
For a single individual student.
So from here also, you can collect it.
Ma'am, we will put it consistently in this pattern.
It will automatically show in detail.
Yes, sir.
It will show in detail.
What you have shown now,
this is just a format to give concession or to apply something.
Right?
But when we are collecting it in the receipt,
it will automatically show, right?
You are saying on the receipt, right?
Yes, sir.
It shows on the receipt.
For example, if we collect it after concession,
it will show that this is the student's concession.
Like I have shown you the receipt format.
It will show if you apply according to it.
It will also be made.
Ok, ma'am.
And this data,
all the transactions that are made,
there is a transaction list above.
From there, common transactions are also made.
This is the transaction list.
The daily transaction will be made.
The whole list is made.
In this, you also have Excel at the top.
You can export according to yourself in Excel.
Ok.
And there are other reports as well.
Anjali, please go back once.
In fee, sir, these are your fee reports.
In this, we have multiple reports.
Daily fee report, combined daily collection,
all these are according to ourselves.
There is a due fee.
You have to check the due fee.
How many students are there?
How much will be received?
How much is pending?
If we take out the total of the students'
default list,
then we will take it out in the due fee, right?
Yes.
Sir, there is an option in the due fee as well.
Anjali, please show the filter.
See, the templates are made.
This is your filter.
Please show the filter.
We will show the filter.
Sir, you will get filters in every report section
Basically, you will have to see
a particular class of the filter.
It will be like this.
There is a class, a stream, a batch.
In this, there is one.
It will be shown to you.
Show student with zero dues.
What does this mean?
For example, you have to see that student
at this time,
whose zero dues are not there.
So you will do it by saying no.
I mean, if it is like this,
that all those who have paid,
it doesn't mean anything.
Those who have pending,
they just want the same.
It is in that case.
Otherwise, if you will do it by saying yes,
then both the students will come together.
Okay.
And we have also taken an awake status.
I think if you know a little about this,
you know that active students
are currently active in our institute.
Awake means,
those who have paid the fees
of this session.
In this case,
you just need those students,
defaulted students,
who have not paid the fees
till now,
one time has passed,
and till now no one has paid.
So we just need the list of those students.
So in that case,
if you will do a false data export,
then only those students will come
who have not paid a rupee
till now for a particular session.
Okay.
In this filter,
is there any particular filter
related to the amount?
That I just have to see
10,000 students who have paid.
For example,
the new students who come,
and I have to say that
I just have to see
10,000 students,
so that they can be seen
by applying the filter.
No, sir.
You will not get anything
Okay.
You just have to see
the new students
up to a particular date.
That is all.
There is a term group,
a date,
that is all.
There is no amount-wise filter, right?
No, sir.
There is no amount-wise.
Because in that case,
it will not be known
because every head has a different amount.
You are saying that
if you want,
then only up to 10,000
will be known, right?
Exactly.
What happens is that
we have a registration
from 10,000.
After a certain time,
we need this list
that the 10,000 students
who have paid,
how many are left?
Because after that,
we consider the fees
that we will not consider
after a certain time.
Then it is necessary.
That is why I was asking
that amount-wise.
That 10,000,
you are saying that
you take it in admission, right?
Yes, yes.
That is different for admission.
You will get that
in the admission reports.
But there also,
there will not be an amount-wise filter, right?
No, sir.
There is no amount-wise.
But no problem,
I will raise it.
If you want,
then you will get it
in a certain time.
No, no.
Okay, okay.
If you think
that you want it,
then there is no problem.
We will raise it in the future.
So, I mean,
we will give a timeline
and you will get that
according to that.
That option too.
Okay.
Okay, sir.
So, these are your reports.
We have seen
different sections
that are coming up
like payable,
with, received.
So, these are your columns
according to that.
For example,
you need a class,
batch,
reg number.
If you don't need
any column,
if you need any column,
then according to that
it becomes yours.
When we will work
on all this,
then only we will know.
Exactly.
Then only we will know.
Basically,
there are reports
like this.
Excel and print
work according to that.
So, this is your fee.
This is what you mean.
you are okay with the fee
and demand.
Yes.
Okay, ma'am.
Okay, sir.
Then you share
your student data.
Yes, ma'am.
So, we will import
of old students.
And with the
data import of old students,
we will also need
dues.
There will be
old dues pending
for many students
who will go ahead.
Okay, yes.
According to that,
we will also impose
So, do you
impose the dues in
the previous dues?
How do you do it?
How urgent is this
base that you are asking
for data of
students,
fees?
old students,
as soon as
your collection
will start.
There is nothing else.
No, I am talking
to you about this
because
the last installment
of the year
is on 10th May.
Okay.
So,
most probably,
around 20th or
20th to
23rd,
our
maximum fee
collection
will have
You will have
the minimum data
that we
have to
collect from
our students.
Okay.
There will be a minimum
data of
If you
fetch that
then I think
you will
feel comfortable
for this.
There is no
issue.
That will also work.
what is there?
There will
not be
2000 students
whose dues
you will
pay.
Sir,
I want to add
We will have
to raise
How will the fees
be collected
No, sir.
So, when are we
going to
start the fees
This is the point.
Sir,
as soon as
your data
starts,
we have to
receive it.
But,
sir,
the
criteria of
fees that
we have
is
so high
that I think
how
we will
work in
speed.
Right now,
tuning
is made
from the
old software.
200-400
people
daily
on the
it now?
No, sir.
That is
a different
You
will
the last
installment.
But,
that
we
have to
raise
the data
of
the
fees of
or
the
50,000
fees
of
will
have to
inserted
to
the
Yes,
we will
that.
Not only
the dues,
but
the
stand.
That is
you
will
send
to
students.
You
will
get
the
yearly
fees.
But,
the
dues
will
not
be
to
But,
the
fees
will
be
sent
to
students.
That is
the data
of
the
student.
But,
fees
be
to
Continue that.
So you can give the data of the concession.
Right, the data of the student.
Whatever you share, as far as I know, there will be no concessions.
Whatever we do, it will stand.
Ok, ok.
No, that's how it is.
Till now, there are no fixed concessions of the children.
We used to have it only after the concession.
It will start from now.
Because the bifurcation and development is starting from you.
It was not there before.
Ok, I understood.
Yes, there is no issue.
How does the hostel stay here?
The hostel has four divisions like tuition fees.
The same hostel comes in four parts.
Transport also comes in four parts.
Only the security is of one time.
Ok, so if I get the data of the hostel, it would be better.
Yes, you will get it.
Whatever we give you, it will also be of the hostel.
Ok, and how will you give the hostel?
You will only give the fees.
Actually, we have the whole hostel module.
There is the same security of 4000 like our fees.
And the fees, for example, if our non AC is 65000,
then the division is in four parts.
Simple.
Ok, I will tell you how it will be.
You told me that it is fee dependent.
You are just telling me about the fees.
The hostel name, right?
What is the room in that hostel name?
What is the bed?
That division is also structured.
If you want to run it, then you can see.
We will talk about that once.
If you want to give it to Warden, it has not been run yet.
But if we get the details of the rooms from there,
then we will definitely get it fetched.
Yes, if it is that one, then that is also not an issue.
In fact, in transport, it is necessary that
the children are divided in the bus number.
As they select the transport area wise,
we will need those divisions.
Yes, there is an effect of transport.
You can also send the transport data.
Did we send the sample Excel?
Or will you send the transport according to yourself?
Sample collection means?
Sample means that we import all the data from Excel.
What is required for that?
Bus number.
What are the pick up points included in the bus number?
We do not have it in so much detail yet.
We will have to create all this now.
Bus wise, the division of the children has not been done yet.
Okay, then how do you take the fees from the students?
Only transport is written.
And those are amount wise divisions.
Let's look at the fees and tell them.
Is it coming from Faridabad or Delhi?
Because the fees are divided.
It is 24,000, 28,000, 32,000.
It is like this.
So you keep it all in that.
Exactly.
There must be a division of four installments.
Yes, there are four installments for that too.
But as we are talking about bus number and this route,
we do not have that division yet.
But we have to get it done.
We will provide this, ma'am.
We will provide this data through transport in charge.
The routes running in front of us,
the route wise and their stoppings,
you also mention that in that.
It is simple.
I will share the sample Excel.
I will share the sample Excel like this.
You will give the particular charges.
Share those respective charges.
They will be prepared easily.
We will import so much time.
Secondly, the accounts,
if it is Excel,
then you tell us in which forum it is.
Or we will provide it in the form that is downloaded.
You are talking about the accounting module?
Yes, the accounts.
The data that you need of the student,
is it in that?
Or the download that we have,
we will download it from Excel and mail it to you.
You can also do that.
Sir, that is more easy.
The data that is already in our software,
we can fetch it.
That is also better.
The student data will be managed.
There is transport, fees,
it is needed that we get the exact amount
as it can be imported.
The student data is done.
The reg number of the child should be unique.
The data that you will get,
whether it is of transport,
it is also of hostel.
And that is accurate.
Okay.
Just one minute, ma'am.
The data that we have,
we have an admission number
and a university roll number.
Okay.
Both these parts will be included
and it will continue.
We will tell you the series
of the new admissions that we are taking.
It will start from the 26th.
Whatever the registration will be,
their numbers will also be included in the series.
Okay, ma'am.
Sir, you told us two numbers.
One is the university registration number
and the other is the university roll number.
Sir, only admission number
and university roll number.
In the primary case,
we have three options.
The admission number is in the primary case.
Yes.
Because when the student is confirmed,
you will get the roll number from the registrar's office.
Okay.
That will be in the data that you will share.
Registration number.
Okay, sir.
Send the student data once.
We have also included sample excel in the mail.
If you want to see.
The mail will be shared with you.
The mail id is with you.
It was with you and Meenakshi ma'am.
Okay.
We have also shared the document.
We want some modules
that are timely implemented.
It will be suitable for you to see
and make changes.
You can see that once.
Update the dates on it.
When can we expect training and all that.
Okay.
And I will share the sample excel
of transport and a hostel
with you.
If you want to run it with your partner,
you can share both.
Basically, the whole hostel will be set up.
Not only fees, you will get everything.
Okay.
Just one minute.
Let's complete.
The registration form
you have given.
We have integrated it.
We will see how it looks.
Yes.
Okay.
Sir, we thought about
meeting the whole admission team.
Sir,
Let's show it once. Anjali, would you please share the screen of the form and the ERP?
Tell me how to do it and how the data will be sent to us via email.
Sir, Vivek sir.
Yes.
We have to show them the modern marketing.
When our registration is complete, then we will do their training.
After the registration of the form, the fees will start coming to you.
After that, we will do their training.
Sir, we are talking about our new student.
Sir, the first part of the new student comes when we have to pay the fees.
But until the data comes, how will you pay the fees?
Sir, you will understand.
We have made the registration form and given it to them.
Yes, we have given it to them.
We have given marketing to them but they are not able to pay the fees.
Sir, that is the purpose of our module.
We want to say that we should get to know how the director is working.
Yes, yes, the payment is not going.
Please tell us how to show the registration.
Sir, we have this form.
Anjali, show the form.
We have put it in a test gate.
We have put it in a test gate so that you can test it according to you.
The day you say live, it will be live.
Live means the actual payment is going to be deducted from it.
Anjali, leave it.
We have this form.
In this form, there will be a detail of your student's name, photo and gender.
Anjali, fill one student form.
We have checked this.
Sir has filled this form with me.
Yes, I have filled this form.
I have filled this form.
Sir, this entry will come on your IERP as soon as you fill this form.
If you will do the payment, then after the payment, the entire transaction will come.
I will show you the transaction.
Anjali, open one entry.
There was a view transaction in this.
You are getting everything on the left side.
No one has done the transaction till now.
You must have filled the over-the-counter form that you will go to the counter and pay.
Click on the admission screen.
It is coming in the bottom.
It will only come forward when you will receive the fees of Rs. 10,000.
This is according.
In case if a student has filled the form, then he will show the receipt in the view transaction.
He will show the receipt here if you have done the payment with the form.
Online.
Anjali, did we do the email later or after filling the survey?
Ma'am, please show me once.
I have done it earlier.
Please fill the form and show me the online payment.
We will do the transaction and see.
Yes, do the transaction.
It is posted.
Anjali, do it.
Should I do it with the sheet?
Do it from here.
Just fill the mandatory details for now.
Anjali, please tell me your email id.
My email id is info at the rate acm.edu.in.
Yes, sir.
info at the rate acm.edu.in.
acm.edu.in.
E-D-U.
E for elephant.
Is it OK, sir?
No, it's not OK.
It's OK now.
The restriction is applied on the basis of the number and 12 digits is taken as the limit.
The restriction is applied on 12 digits.
Otherwise, children will give you wrong information.
I will note it.
Restriction on hand.
I don't know if you know, I'll show you, I mean, how much is it?
Whose charges are these?
Sir, these are the charges of the payment gateway of the bank.
Mom, isn't it more than 10,000?
One minute, let me check.
We don't have any charges on it.
That's what I was asking once.
Sir, tell him once.
You didn't?
No, so ma'am, the charges you are taking on the razor with me, what will it take at what rate?
Please share with me once.
No, I will share the details.
Actually, I don't have it.
I got it from him.
So I will share all the property details with you.
And we will also try to make it competitive, ma'am.
Yes, I will show you how it is.
She will have a discussion with him.
Because there is a gateway issue, ma'am.
Otherwise, our bank has its own gateway.
Otherwise, we will do it from our own gateway.
Because we will not charge so much.
No problem, sir.
She will discuss it once.
Yes, I will share the details.
I will have a proper discussion with the ones I have set up.
Yes, ma'am.
In that, all your charges are there.
Your credit card charges.
Whatever charges you want.
Yes, I will tell you.
It shows like this.
Scan it and do it like this.
The test mode is coming up.
UPI.
Anjali will not scan it now.
She will scan it, sir.
After that, she will go to the payment.
I mean, the payment is done.
Because it will be scanned now.
After scanning the amount, the amount is deducted.
And after that, it is redirected.
No, the receipt.
I had a question.
How will you show the test receipt?
The one you must have made.
Sir, he is saying that after taking 10,000.
The form that will come to you.
Of the fee registration.
How does it look?
Show me that.
How will the transaction be?
Go to ERP.
How will the show be in the registration receipt?
This will be done in dummy.
Yes, show it in dummy.
Not this, sir.
Not this, Anjali.
Go to admission.
Admission data.
Ma'am, won't it be checked with one rupee?
Sir, it is fixed.
It won't be checked with one rupee.
Because the amount that was fixed on it.
It won't be edited.
Sir, don't fix it.
I am saying the same thing.
Why have we fixed it on 10,000?
There should be a variation.
Okay.
Don't skip it.
Anjali, you have to pay.
Pay it and save.
It will be saved like this.
Sir, this type of receipt is cut.
It will have the same receipt.
Cancel it.
Cancel.
Show it in the transaction.
It will be cut by the student.
No, not here.
Open the application in admission.
Here is the transaction.
Sir, the transaction will come here.
Don't print it.
This is the admission transaction.
It comes like this.
Our logo is not being displayed.
Ma'am, I want to see it.
Thank you.
Share it in the group.
Because you had formatted it.
Not everyone has the information of the form.
Your documents go to the same place.
We have to adjust it.
Sir, please check the receipt for the fee.
We have to make some changes.
Sir, cash is being written in it.
We were doing it online.
If you do it online, it will be written online.
I have done it online.
Okay.
The receipt number is done.
The admission number will come automatically.
One minute.
When the receipt comes,
we will fetch it.
After that, the admission number will be created.
No, sir.
The admission number will come after that.
This is going to be a token.
Yes.
The payment mode is visible.
Instrument, instrument number.
Date is done.
Sir,
student name is done.
Everything is done.
The form number is the same.
The application will be written
on the form number.
Even the application will go to the student.
When this is done,
it will be shown in the accounts.
Yes, it will be shown in the accounts.
The registration form
will also be shown.
Yes, it can be done.
Cancel it, Anjali.
Okay.
the print form will be done.
This is okay.
I wanted to test it
The way they pay the money
we wanted to see
whether the payment
payment was coming
on the e-mail or not.
You are going.
When is the e-mail?
Recipts are also going to the student's mail?
Yes, yes.
Sir, there will be a form in the student's mail
where it will be written that the student has paid
like this.
Now the actual receipts have to be collected from here
from the counter for confirmation.
No, it can't be that
it goes to the mail.
Sir, look, sometimes it gets risky.
By chance, the child has a refund after that.
Think about it, sometimes it happens.
You must still have the bank
that the bank has taken the money
but within 3 days it is not confirmed
for any explicit reason and then
the refund is going to it.
No, no, refund means
the amount is back.
Yes, it happens.
What is the problem with that?
It gets cancelled.
For example, the child has filled
the amount.
You are getting the receipt from him
and the receipt should not be generated at that time
when the receipt has been generated.
Ma'am,
he has paid
and by chance, if he does the back
then our regular receipts
also have a lot of back.
So we have to do the transaction.
That is a part of
accounts.
Bounce, check, pay.
Sir, I will discuss this one
once that the receipt
is going to him. You are saying that the receipt
that he has paid to the child is also
going to him. After that, if it gets cancelled
then it is a different matter.
It should be entered.
That is the same thing. I will see
it once. The receipt is going.
The receipt is not going on the phone.
Basically, if we are there
but we had to give the manual
then we are saying that we are not completely online.
We have something offline.
Yes, I understood. The receipt is also
basically the same.
Generally, we have told the team
that the customer
is going to receive the receipt.
My continued discussion with them is
that after the registration form
when the child will fill
and he has paid
then our two things will be processed
on his email. First, the receipt
and second, our digital
prospectus
will directly
be diverted on his email.
That is it.
That is what you get me to do the testing.
After this, I will make them live
that is our admission team.
Okay, sir.
When is the payment gateway charges?
I mean the payment gateway charges.
Yes, I told you.
Until now, such charges do not
apply on our portal.
If you fill the online form
then it is 10,000 only.
Yes.
When are the charges in it?
When someone does it with credit card
or credit card
then also the minimum charges
as per bank norms are applied.
But it is not such charges
that 15-18% is applied.
Okay.
Ma'am, please tell me in detail
how and what is it?
I will share this.
Actually, I just got it applied.
I will share that as well.
Okay.
Ma'am, two things are clear to you.
Fees, whether it is offline payment
or online payment.
The receipt will go to the student.
First. Arrestation.
Wait a minute, sir. You will only pay
in offline payment, right? I mean if you
have taken cash from the counter.
Ma'am, but it should show in the mail
that he has paid today.
Yes, it will show in the mail
that he is paying over the counter fee.
Yes, ma'am.
It will show.
Basically, the hard copy
is being taken from our counter
but the soft copy is also being taken from the counter.
He is still sleeping.
Should I check my email?
Sir, you must have received a mail.
Will you submit it to Anjali?
Yes, I will check it.
Should I approve it as well?
No, I am asking if you have submitted the form
in which we had taken the application.
Yes, the payment was left.
No, no. Submit it. It will be fully submitted.
Submit it in some way and submit it.
Ma'am, it will show when you submit it.
How should I submit it fully?
You just scan it.
Anjali, just scan it.
It will be joined with the form.
Ma'am, please put one rupee in it.
It will be scanned like this.
Sir, it is a test mode. It will not be cut off.
It will be done automatically.
Then it is good.
Anjali, please scan it once.
Ma'am, what has happened now is
that the children who have filled the details
have received the registration form copy.
Hmm.
There is nothing else after that.
There is nothing else.
Ram sir, but their payment has not been made yet.
Ram sir, how will it be seen from there?
Kajish ma'am, should I do it with GP?
With UPI?
Just scan it with a scanner like this, Anjali.
Ma'am, I am not good with that.
Scan it with GP.
Just scan it like this.
Ma'am, it is a test mode. It is not happening.
It is not happening.
No, it can't be done with the QR code.
Yes, it is a test mode.
It is coming.
Okay, now do an over-the-counter.
That will go to sir.
Ma'am, then do a change in it.
The restriction that you have applied 10,000 times.
Hmm.
Do it manually.
Fill it as much as you want.
Then apply the restriction later.
Okay.
Actually, we are waiting for you
to hand over this page to the marketing team
Anjali, go to the form.
Leave it. It will be done later.
Leave it.
Back it.
Yes, do it.
Now cancel it.
That one will also be done later.
Okay, sir. Tell me one more thing.
Yes.
I will put you on the amount.
First, I will give you the confirmation
of how to do the amount.
Because payment gateway is taking charges.
Yes.
Okay.
And
basically, I have to work on your form.
You will share the student data.
That will be imported.
And you have to send me a transport card.
Done.
Okay, sir. Tell me one more thing.
I will share this with you.
Okay, ma'am.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, sir.
Thank you, ma'am.
Anjali.
Hmm.
You don't show the Zoho form.
You were showing the Zoho form.
Why don't you show the Zoho form?
One minute.